There are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time,
so we gathered some of
the most-hyped products
to test for ourselves.
This is a Face Sprinkles mini palette
from Designer Dust Co.
They have a lot of different
ones to choose from,
and you can even make a custom palette
with any of their glitters.
I was trying to show all of the colors,
but I couldn't lift it all the way
because one of the glitters
was completely liquefied.
Something weird happened
to it on its way to me,
but the rest of the
glitters were totally fine.
The glitter has a vegan
gel base that dries down.
You can apply it on the
face, hair, or body.
I was having fun just
putting it everywhere.
I loved all the colors,
and it was really easy to apply.
I'm not really into glitters,
but I think these worked great,
and this is one of the more affordable
glitter gel palettes I've seen.
This is the Summer
Fridays sheer skin tint.
It's supposed to be
lightweight, hydrating,
and very natural on the skin.
I definitely think it
is all of those things.
The coverage is obviously sheer,
but I was able to build it up no problem.
It evened out my skin nicely,
and it actually does feel weightless.
This would be a great
everyday skin tint for me.
I think for what it is and
how little product you get,
$42 is way too much.
But if you're looking
for a high-end skin tint,
this one is really nice.
I had been getting ads
for this Flower Knows
Strawberry Rococo collection for weeks,
and they definitely worked on me
because I bought three products.
First up, I tried the embossed blush.
The detail in the embossing is so cool.
I didn't even want to use it.
They do say that this is
meant to be a buildable blush,
but I think the color payoff
is a little too light.
It took me forever to get
the color payoff I wanted,
but it did look pretty in the end.
On to the eye-shadow palette.
The matte formula was soft and blendable,
but next time I would go
in with a primer first,
because it was slightly
patchy in some areas.
The glitter shade was incredible.
It was definitely the best
shade in the entire palette,
but it did give me some fallout.
Lastly, I tried the Cloud lip cream.
This is one of those mousse-y lip formulas
that has a velvety finish.
This felt really nice and
comfortable on the lips,
and I like the blurred effect it gives,
but I kind of wish it was the
same red as the packaging.
This is the Caliray So Blown clean primer.
It's one of those
dimethicone-y blurring primers
that makes your skin look matte.
I actually like how it made my skin look
without any foundation.
It feels nice and velvety,
and I definitely saw some blurring.
When I applied my foundation,
I realized I applied
too much of the primer,
so my skin actually
looked kind of textured
and the product pilled up a bit.
So the next time I tried it,
I went in with less and
focused on my oily areas,
and I still wasn't loving
how my foundation looked over this.
I just see way more
texture with this primer
than my normal primer.
I'll show them side by side,
so maybe you can kind of see what I mean.
I don't think that this is for me.
Milani released this
Conceal + Perfect line
with liquid under-eye brighteners,
contours, and highlighters.
These kind of feel like
a drugstore version
of the Charlotte Tilbury wands.
First, I tried the brightener
under my concealer.
I didn't notice much brightening at first,
but then I applied it with my fingertips
and got some better coverage.
Next, I tried the liquid contour.
This color does lean a little
bit red, which I don't love,
but it blended out really beautifully
and added a nice warmth to my face.
I applied the highlighter
next, and I loved this.
Again, it blends out really nicely,
and it doesn't add any texture to my skin.
It just gave a really pretty glow.
Even though I don't see
myself using the brightener,
I am a fan of these,
and I hope they expand the shade range.
These are the Kaleidos Epiphany Glow
Melt-On eyeliners.
They're all multichrome,
so they have these
really cool color shifts.
"Melt-On" was the perfect
description for these,
because they really do glide on so easily.
I've never had such a
smooth eyeliner application,
because they always
skip or they're too dry.
These are so easy to apply.
I thought that the tip would be too blunt
to create a wing, but I was actually
able to do it without any issue.
These are really beautiful,
and I highly recommend them.
I hope they expand the line
to include more everyday matte shades.
This is the Got2b Glued
for brows and edges.
For a long time, people have been using
Got2b hair gel as brow gel,
so they came out with this product
that's actually meant for brows.
I actually like how
this made my brows look.
It gives kind of a laminated brow effect,
nice and feathery,
but the gel itself left
a weird residue behind,
and it took forever to dry down.
Once it did dry, the brows
pretty much stayed in place,
but I've definitely
tried better brow gels.